fall in love in different ways like men
um fall in love through like quality
time and loyalty where women fall in
love through sex so if you have sex like
have you ever heard you okay you've
never heard the term dickmatized yeah
sterling
you're just literally
just like how men have lust it's exactly
this i would argue that's how women feel
love is like when they're when they're
like okay i'll give you a story okay so
there is a girl i went to college with
and you would never know this is like
the girl next door okay she dated a guy
freshman year of college they did it for
like a month okay they broke up
he dumped her whatever like he's the
player right she gets with a guy her
senior year
this man buys her a house she's like it
gives her everything she ever wants a
ring whatever down the line
i went to a party with this girl okay
and at that party
i saw her
walk out of the bathroom after she'd
been in there for like 20-30 minutes um
because we were like waiting to go with
the guy from freshman year who does she
love
who does she love so you would have to
ask her but i don't know so who was she
going to leave she was still sleeping
with the guy from freshman year for
years yeah that's what i'm saying like
like oh and the crazy thing not loved
because the sex was good yeah it's it's
a habit no ice is an an attachment but
that doesn't make it love women don't
cheat on men they love yeah
they
women
must be taking the piss
hey have you considered this maybe maybe
you're taking the piss because you
believe something that's never going to
happen
i think a lot of times women find
themselves very very upset and feeling
alone and went through a bunch of men
and
unhappy
single no kids cat boxes box wine
netflix alone because they bought the
dream that prince charming was gonna
come on a horse and be rich and be
handsome and be tall and not [ __ ] a
bunch of ladies i i hear what you're
saying and i think that that is sorry
that is the reality for um for
unfortunately for a lot of women because
we are socialized to be to have this
romantic notion of relationships and
that this prince charming is going to
come and that sort of thing but
at the same time especially like someone
my age and like just seeing the women
around me that kind of filters out like
we the way we've been socialized it's
just not the reality anymore we can see
the the the smoke um we could see
through the smoke
and lighter your whole life yeah yeah
you have no reason
and that's the thing and i think that a
lot of women are waking up to this fact
that actually this is a myth this is
nonsense like that's never going to
happen so
so what you're saying why aren't women
settling
why are they settling no why aren't they
women are settling that's why
statistically that's so high no that's
not true like half of women over 30 are
single and childless
half of women oh you mean like settling
for an average yeah like getting an
average guy and everything
80 of women want 20 of the men so if you
ask 80 of women what they want in a guy
they list 20 percent of men so the men
that we want there's just not enough to
go around yeah they do so sorry so
so we always talk we always talk about
like never settle never settle never
settle but we just end up alone no i
think i think a lot of women settle
maybe that's not um
obvious to people but a lot of women are
sailing i think and because we have so
much pressure in society that you can't
be alone you can't be happy and alone or
you can't you know i mean that you don't
have a fulfilling life if you don't have
children and that is that is a problem
but like society's viewpoint needs to
change but no because the thing is if
you choose to have a relationship and be
in the scenario that you're talking
talking about with full honesty that's
one thing that's okay do you know what i
mean but if you're choosing not to that
should also be okay you shouldn't be
victimized or demonized because you
choose something it's not that it's not
it's not that you're demonized though
like i think
because one i see propaganda all the
time talking about how like women over
40 are super happy like i see this all
the time like oh it's okay to be alone
never settle da da da da like i see the
opposite propaganda honestly and on top
of that like
women 45 single and childless are the
least happy demographic
i just don't know how you prove that no
no because they survey people
they serve it they certainly this is
this is what this is what i mean like i
know no i'm not like the same but it
just seems so general and it just seems
like i i just like pulling we're
biologically programmed to want children
yeah i would not naturally everybody
you're right not everybody is but the
majority of us are and typically when i
see a woman that doesn't want kids like
she somehow was hurt in the past and
that's why she doesn't it's like i think
i start out i think every woman starts
her life out wanting a family in kids
and then at some point
society gets in her head
bad experiences get in her head and that
warps that the woman that says she
doesn't want kids is just as much of an
outlier as a man that says he doesn't
want to cheat
bingo hold on
mike drop you're very funny
you're not absolutely right and you have
nothing to say to it i'm right you're
wrong
i just i i don't agree with the fact
that oh no it doesn't feel good it's a
fact it's it's not even a fact because i
don't know how it feels
really isn't about how it feels it's
just like having a lived experience and
having people around that have actually
gone through this and this is their
experience and them not being this these
idea these these these mythical women
that you think they are do you know what
i mean right so 65
you're gonna like you're 65 yeah and
you're gonna live another 20 30 like
let's say you lived in 90.
you're gonna be happy no family nothing
just by yourself with a career
so you know you will say no family as in
no kids of your own yeah no kids no
husband okay
you don't have friends it doesn't mean
that you don't have family around
children nieces and nephews you know
what i mean so there are other ways to
find happiness and i think that that is
okay and i just don't like the fact that
you know it's pushed that it's not okay
and then for women to be pushed into
relationships that they're not happy in
them and they're not going to be
fulfilled in and like do you know what i
mean i just think it just needs to be
equal or level but i don't
what i'm not saying is it's not okay i
think people can if you want to do that
if like people want to do that do it but
what i think is dishonest is lying to
women and telling them you're going to
be happy without a husband without a
family at 65 because if we take if we
take sample sizes we survey women that
are single childless at 65 in different
cities across the country
it comes with the same result they're
the least happy and so you can say oh i
don't believe the data but like how much
i understand maybe you don't believe me
maybe like that's that's another thing
but like how much evidence do you need
if people themselves are saying i am the
least happy demographic when they are
serving i would need to see the data
okay and i have a comment on the data as
well i took this um yale university
course on happiness
and they did a study and they found that
your happiness level
is gonna be up two years when you get
married and then it's gonna it's gonna
go down to the same level when you are
single mm-hmm well honeymoon period
isn't it really yeah right right so
which is also biological yes yeah make
sure the kid makes it yes
oh interesting i didn't know that yeah
who's going to keep who's going to keep
the pregnant woman alive and make sure
the baby gets through infancy yeah yeah
about 18 months that's why they say also
if you're dating a girl then you don't
have kids so if you've why a lot of
relationships sort of split after about
two years two three years it's because
if you haven't produced a child then
sort of biologically
you know internally the woman and the
band probably like what's the point yeah
exactly exactly there's nothing bonding
them together yeah it's just yeah right
and other mammals like giraffes they
they have the baby and the baby pops out
to walk
you know but that's not like that with a
human baby we're different
yeah it's different that thing is
useless yeah for two years kind of a
walk well no i mean
it doesn't make no way
yeah defensiveness yeah
i don't i don't get what you guys are
saying because more people are in like
long relationships and they don't
generally get married
yeah it's like i don't see how this that
would stack up to this two-year thing
how many
more people are living together honest
questions for longer how many like
long-term married couples do you know
that i'm super
that are
super happy who's who
you should really be asking me is how
many people do i know
that are super happy that's not what i'm
asking you but that would be the you
know couples it goes up and down how
many couples do i know that have been in
long-term relationships quite a few
of those how many of them are like how
many of them are i only okay so i have
eight friends who have been in a
relationship as long as me and my
husband 20 years cool
congratulations by the way that's
actually amazing and only one
of them
has just got divorced and we all kind of
got together divorced no i'm saying
but all of us are
as happy as the next human next door
it's like you go up and down
cooper the happiest man
we're happy in our unions or we would
get divorced no and that's great and
that's the thing but so there's quite a
few if you're in that vortex if you're
not going to see the opposite i don't
think
that
people can people will
immediately divorce if they're unhappy
in a relationship well i think it would
be stupid
if somebody came to me and was like
i'm really unhappy in my marriage
i want to get a divorce i'd be like
no
that's not the step you take clever
there are loads of things that you work
on because happiness goes up and down
it's a scale it's just lots of things
will make you happy what you really want
is contentment and you want to be secure
and you want to have a super objective
for your life
and if the person works with that and
you can fulfill that that's where you
want to be because happiness is fleeting
you know the best the best super
objective is
children kids
um they they can't be the only thing
because obviously
they grow up and they'll leave you well
that is the best example of a super yeah
well it's at least 18 years it's one of
them it's one to have it's one to have
to keep you bonded to but then your
super objective doesn't necessarily have
to be having the child it should really
be more of the type of human that you
actually want to co-create and actually
build to be
significant and productive in society
and that would be your super objective
it's not to just have the baby because
you could have the child and their
bloody hard work
make the child a killer make their child
amazing i agree with that that's right
that can be your objective for you know
20 years i know that's mine and maybe
that's my objective you can change again
because we live so long now and then you
can be like we've done what we set out
to do for our 25 years and maybe me and
you can just be bedrooms and we can move
on again or or
we redirect that energy again that's it
if it works
our kids kids yeah and that's cool and
then we can be effective grandparents
and you can go in that way and that's
called legacy too the other so we're
talking about women that are single and
childless over a certain age the other
issue with that is that there's a large
proportion of women that will be on the
streets because they don't have the 2.5
million that they need to retire
2.5 million you need 2.5 million today
in the uk
oh i'm sorry this is a us stat i forget
about that i forget that the structure
is different
i mean we have pensions
the idea is that well
in the u.s the idea is that a lot of the
government handouts are going to run out
because it's just not
sustainable long term they're kind of
have that happen too yeah so when the
day that comes when they actually have
to stop giving government handouts
there's a lot of women that are going to
be on the streets because we own 80 of
consumer debt
yeah goddamn yeah so so
yeah including college debt yeah and
college debt is the biggest i mean
that's that's a u.s issue here i think
the school is free but
no you still have that but you don't pay
it you don't pay it back unless you
reach a certain level of income yeah you
don't have to yeah oh okay that's
actually and it cuts out at 65 or
something does it yeah yeah it does
it's a third year debt right right okay
yeah i don't i don't know all the time
just just like just play devil's
advocate on that point a little bit
though is it is should somebody
therefore say oh well in case i end up
on the street and i haven't got 2.5
million when i'm 65 i should therefore
check out with the dude i would
i mean yeah but
let's be completely clear everybody in
this room would every one of you ladies
would because you'd have no choice and
that's the way it was before all this
[ __ ] yeah i was just like saying so
we'll just go back to the 50s where
you're literally what no 18 years
when you needed to be married to just
have a bank account so you just go you'd
be in your old age and you'd be like
okay i'm going to shack up with winston
down the road and so then i can survive
winston's great is it
a little random noodle some netflix
might have sex counterproductive to the
whole
woman being an independent woman and so
that's why she hasn't set her sights out
to be married would she not have been
stacking her p's so she would be okay at
65. probably better than
others i know like like the average
income of a i don't know what it is here
but i know it's similar so in the u.s
the average income of a woman is around
35 000
so so she she doesn't have enough money
to stack her p's and be the independent
women if you look at the numbers like
what percent of women are making six
figures it's not a very high amount
it's less than 10. i would like to see
in relation to single women who are over
40
and how much money they are earning but
in that 25 years that how many of them
would be the ones that would be homeless
i i would
say that it's probably not going to be
that high there may be some i mean you
know whatever happens but again people
aren't families like they do have
relatives they do have siblings there
are other people that are in their
family i don't think there'll be that
many well but people well but the thing
is like women are the
biggest growing homeless population
so so it's happening you could say like
oh i don't think that many of them it'll
happen to you but if 50 of women over 30
are single and childless that's a very
big percentage of the population those
are interesting ways of saying stats
though because whenever you say growing
it's like when people say like um
mixed-race children are the the biggest
growing ethnicity in the uk they are
still like literally like 0.2
so
growing doesn't mean that we should be
like oh it's going to happen it's just
maybe there's more than there was before
i know there's but there's more stats
that i'm bringing to you like i'm
telling you that 50 of the population is
single and childless you need 2.5
million to retire and on top of that the
average income of a woman is 35 000 per
year or four
it's between 35 and 45 it's around there
a year in the united states and it's
similar here so and on top of that the
biggest growing homeless population
is single childless women so it's it's
like all of those numbers together
show that you know that's not
like the single modern women it's that's
not a good look for them i don't even
want to say look it's not good outcomes
or
the outcomes that were there before when
you were settling for a man and getting
beaten up and were thoroughly unhappy
and having loads of kids then you don't
have any choices to do yeah i'm just
saying like
we're doing sweeping statements so i'm
offering another counter too no i know
maybe this is the shift of reality but
what evidence do you have that women
were being beat like do you think the
majority of men were beating up women in
the 1950s no it wasn't the majority but
there was a large amount and you also
didn't have the means the capacity or
the societal support to leave so you
stayed in relationships because that's
what you had to do now that's shifting
now so you don't have to be in a
relationship so maybe the offshoot of
that is that some people are not going
to be in a relationship they would have
lived their life they would have spent
their money how they were going to spend
their money and they may have loads of
debt but
that could just be a consequence of
freedom cool i some people would decide
i want to be free then have to be bonded
to an average man yeah but yeah i would
also add to what you're saying is yeah
maybe you're right but the reason she is
right is because big daddy government
has stepped in and given women
this other way they're going to give
them all these jobs but what she's
saying is because they only make 35
grand a year because they don't have the
2.5 million because we are running out
the ball's about to drop on that what
what would you do if let's just say
tomorrow
an emp drops on the whole world electro
big big pulse
internet's gone
all computers are gone we're back to the
stone age right what would you do then
would you okay some guy some guy who's
average
comes along is like i want to marry you
and put a baby in you and raise a family
with you we've got this farmland we're
going to grow crops by the way i can
hunt by the way i can shoot a gun and
haunted deer
oh no sorry you're not good looking
enough no no i'm not on it like all of
that like massive changes it's cool i
can go with the smash and and leave so
i'm too old go and find someone younger
so
yeah the situation we find ourselves in
right now is a product of the times
we're in which is this like justin just
said this kind of
nanny state
right the government is
most people are suckling on the teat of
government in some way shape or form
right or they're being parasitized by
the government
if you're actually producing money and
you're being parasitized your taxes are
massive right i mean we don't live in
this country but we're in a different
country and we know that's the case so
it it
we we find ourselves in this really
unique time in history
where
men and women
are being
put in a combative situation
rather than a complementary one
we're naturally complementary to each
other we're supposed to be together well
we we take away the consequence so like
before if you were if you were single
and alone you'd be you'd be homeless
and now there's no consequence for that
because the government's bailing people
out